Good morning John!
So I have a head cold, which I would complain
about, except that you just got home from
the hospital 'cause you have viral meningitis.
Which is maybe a little bit worse than a cold,
uhh, so I feel like I should suck it up and
just do my best to entertain you and make
you feel better while your head is trying
to fall off of your body, so here's a monkey
selfie! Isn't that a cute monkey?
This picture was taken when photographer David
Slater's camera was stolen by a Rare Crested
Black Macaque. That macaque then proceeded
to take lots and lots of pictures of itself,
of other macaques, of just... leaves. Most
of them were terrible - like anybody with
a DSLR.
But this one was very good, and not only because
the macaque has the beautiful smile on its
face and he's in focus and there's a nice
depth of field thing going on and it's good
composition, but also because the idea of
selfies has sort of permutated culture and
is now a thing.
And the idea of a monkey taking a selfie is
kind of silly and funny and people want to
put that on their blogs. All of this has combined
into this become David Slater's most famous
photograph ever - most successful photograph
ever. At least, by some measures.
The problem is that David Slater makes his
living by selling photographs, but this picture
has been declared by the Wikimedia Foundation
as being in the public domain, meaning it's
free for everyone to use.
Why? This is David Slater's photograph - he
should have the ability to sell it.
Well... he didn't take it. It was taken by
a monkey, and monkeys, at least so far, are
not legally able to own things, anything,
including intellectual property.
This is unfortunate for David Slater who carried
lots of very heavy and expensive equipment
a very long way to get this photograph, but
it seems to me like the Wikimedia Foundation's
argument makes sense. It's everybody's photo,
which is why I can use it in this video, because
macaques can't own stuff.
Anyhow, viral meningitis! Woah... huh!?
If you're confused, John, who is the other
half of this video blog --if you're very confused
-- is my brother and he got viral meningitis
last week. He's home from the hospital now,
he's fine, although he's still in a significant
amount of pain.
This has resulted in a first-ever-of-all-time
thing on Vlogbrothers: I have three videos
in a row on this channel... because Esther
Day happened as well, and John missed a video,
and so now... Wow... it's like the Hank Show...
I don't like it.
Please, John, come back, because I don't know
what to talk about without riffing off of
you.
John has now missed three videos because of
hospitalizations...
Once for his orbital cellulitis - when his,
the back of his eyeball got infected. Once
for his gallbladder being removed, and now
for viral meningitis. Stop, John, stop.
That first time John missed his video, when
he had the orbital cellulitis, the eye infection,
we banded together and we made a nice video
to help him feel better -- people put stuff
on their heads for him. Because putting stuff
on your head is funny and it makes people
feel better. It's a well-known scientific
fact... uh there's journal articles all about
it. Oooh!
So I'm gonna do it again and, in the spirit
of questionable copyright, I'm gonna do it
with the help of my friend Calvin Harris.
[singing]
Meningitis is a bummer,
When your head starts to pound,
The stiffness in the neck and
the sensitivity to sound,
Rising pressure in your cranium,
and your blood pressure down,
Your brain gets starved for oxygen now,
but you will rebound,
Meningitis is a bummer
John, I really, really, really, really, really
hope that I'll see you on Tuesday, uh, 'cause
I don't wanna do this by myself anymore.
It's not Vlogbrother!!